hey everyone welcome to simply launch
youtube channel today we are going to
discuss one of the most interesting
topics which is the coin change problem
in dynamic programming
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates and multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply now now without any further ado
let's get started with our agenda for
today's session
first we will define the coin change
problem following that we will look the
coin chain problem using dynamic
programming
finally we will look into the steps of
coin change problem
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now let's begin with our first
topic and attempt to comprehend the coin
change problem the coin change problem
is defined as the total number of ways
you can change the given amount of money
using the coins
and we are provided with different types
of coins or coins of varying
denominations and a specific amount that
is w
let's look into an example
the denominations of the coins are 1 2
and 3 and 5 is the weight
so how can we achieve a weight five with
three coins there are number of ways to
do this first we will need five one
rupee coins
the second way to make five is to use
three one rupee coins and one two rupee
coin the third way of doing it is using
two one rupee coins and one three rupee
coins
the fourth way is to use one two rupee
coin and one three rupee coin
and the last way is using one two rupee
coin and one three rupee coin
there is no other way to make the number
five using one two and three rupee coins
so in total we have five ways to make
weight equal to 5 using these coins
now we will see how dynamic programming
can be used to solve the coin change
problem
let us suppose we have a different
demonstration of coin as 2 3 and 5 and
we have to make the total sum weight as
8 with the same condition that we can
use an infinite number of coin supplies
we must generate a table in the coin
change problem using dynamic programming
because we will store the results and
use them later
so in this table the column side will
have coin values of 2 3 and 5 and the
row will have to store the weight by
dividing it into smaller ways because in
dynamic programming we will divide
problems into sub problems that are 0 1
2 3 4 until 8.
here are three simple steps of solving
the coin change problem with dynamic
programming
the first step is to exclude the coin
the second step is to include the coin
and the final step is to add the first
and second steps
let's start with the coin of
demonstration
two and the sum is zero so there's only
one way to go
because if we don't choose the coin
value 2 we'll obviously make sum or
weight as 0 and the same goes for coin 3
and 5 so we'll write 1
1 and 1 below the sum of zero
now that the sum is one
we can make it one using a coin value of
two
the answer is no
we can't make it one using a coin value
of two so we will fill 0 in here
next we must make the sum 2 using 2
rupee coin and there is only one way to
do so use 1 2 rupee coin
next we can make a sum of three using a
coin of denomination two the answer is
no so we'll mark this entry as zero
we can now make a sum of four by using a
coin with a value of two rupee coins in
only one way so we'll update one as the
location changes
in the same way we will update the
entire row of coin denominations two
now that we have a new coin with a
denomination of 3
we will have one trick if the coin value
is greater than the sum
simply copy the first values above
for example if the coin value is 3 and
the sum is 1 we will simply copy the
value
which is above which is 0.
again
the coin value is 3 and the sum is 0
which is less than the current value so
we will simply copy the value above
which is 1.
next
we have sum of three and current value
of three that is not greater than three
we will now proceed with those simple
three steps
if we exclude coin value three we simply
copy the value above which is 0 and if
we exclude coin value 3 we subtract that
same row beat that 3 bitcoin value that
is also 3
which gives us 0 and what we have below
weight 0 in the same row is 1 so we will
add both values that 0 and 1 which gives
us 1.
next
for sum 4 we exclude coin value 3 we
must simply copy the value which is
above which is 1 and by including 3 we
must subtract the sum value which is 4
from the coin value which is 3 which
gives on
and what we have below some one in the
same row is zero so we add zero and one
which is one
so in the same manner we will fill out
all the entries for some five 6 7 and 8
of three coin denominations
now that we have coin value 5
we use the same trick if coin value 5 is
greater than the sum of 1 which is true
we simply copy the values which are
lying above the row so we have done for
the first row that is 0 so by excluding
coin value 5 and we are left with 2 and
3 and what we have of coin 2 and 3 in
the same row is 0 and 1 and the sum of 0
and 1 which gives 1 and by including
coin value 5 we have to subtract sum to
coin value 5 which gives 0 and what we
have below the sum of 0 of the same row
which is 1 so 1 plus 1 gives 2 so we
update the same
the sum is now 6 and the coin value is
also 5 so if we exclude coin the value 5
we are left with 2 and 3 and
what we have of coin 2 and 3 is the same
row is 1 and 2
and the sum of 1 and 2 which gives 3 and
we include coin value 5
we have to subtract sum of
6 with coin value 5
which gives us 1 and what we have below
the sum 1 of the same row which is 0 so
sum of three plus zero gives us three we
will update the same
so in the same manner we will fill out
all the entries of sums of seven and
eight of five coin denominations
so in the end we got three which is our
answer indicating that we have a minimum
of three ways to make the sum of eight
using denomination coin value which is
two three and five now in this video we
will go over all the steps that we went
to solving the coin change problem with
dynamic programming first we had a 2d
array named coin change which has i as
the number of rows and j as the number
of columns now in this algorithm
we will have two for loops one for i and
another for checking the values of
columns within i that is true
so the first loop runs from zero to the
maximum length of the coin
which is the coin dot length and the
second loop runs for the first column to
the weight
if coils of i are greater than j we
simply copy coin change of i of j is
equal to the coin change f i minus 1 of
j otherwise we must apply the three step
formula coin change of i of j is equal
to coin change of i minus 1 of j plus
coin change of i of j minus coin of i
lastly we will see the practical
implementation
so on my screen you can see a program
example for coin change problem
first we finished all the necessary
header files standard library standard
library strings which all the strings
are defined and the console input output
library so first we have a function
called collect which has an array called
sum and two variables called m and n for
number of coins and and number of weight
so this is our first function
so m is number of coins and n is the
weight then in this function we declared
four variables
two counter variables and
in variable for including the coin value
and x variable for excluding the coin
value then we declared our 2d array
which is a coin change array in which we
need n plus one rules because the coin
change is built from the bottom up using
base case zero
next we have two for loops one for row
that will run until the coin length is
reached and another for column that will
run until the sum or weight is reached
in this follow
we will first include the coin value j
we get the value after subtracting the j
value from the coin value i if the coin
value i is greater than 0 we simply
assign the coin change of i minus the
coin change of the same column
if we exclude the coin value from this
we have the condition that if jth value
is greater than one we assign coin
change
of i of j minus one otherwise we assign
zero alternatively simply return the
coin change from m of m minus one
next we have the main function in which
we declare the array of coin values and
assign the coin values of 2 3 and 5 then
we have the same
m variable in which we divide the coin
and then we have variable n in which we
have sum as 8 and finally we print the
total number of coin combinations that
sums up
now
let's quickly execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
output over here
and this example we considered is the
same which one we have discussed before
and the final value is 3 that you can
see over here
and you can see the answer as the total
number of combinations of coins that sum
up to value eight is three
now with that we have come to an end of
this video if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you need the code
that we have executed in this particular
tutorial then please feel free to let us
know in the comment section below our
team of experts will be happy to resolve
all your queries until next time thank
you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here